welcome to Simply learn in this video we
will see the Hands-On demonstration of
Google Keyword Planner Moss Google
search console and more SEO tools so
before we begin consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us and what
we're going to do is start out with
search engine optimization okay so
search engine optimization or organic
search we have mixture of paid and free
so there's a lot of different platforms
but if you're focusing on SEO you
certainly need to use an SEO platform so
there's sem Rush okay you also have
Google search console which is free so
if you don't have a SEO platform you
definitely need to be using Google
search console and so we'll take a
closer look at that there's Google
Keyword Planner which is actually
situated under Google ads and so if
you're running Google Google campaigns
on Google search Network or even the
Display Network you have access to a
great tool called keyboard planner and
if you know anything about SEO you'll
know that using Google's Keyword Planner
is a good tool so we'll take a look at
that MZ is a premium tool meaning they
have a free trial that you can sign up
for to test drive it but it's another
SEO platform and it does cost money got
a great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in HRS
that help us with all aspects of SEO
primarily focusing on off page so these
are just some examples that we're going
to hone in on but this is just a small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about SEO is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
Keyword Planner and Google's Keyword
Planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested
and optimizing for because not only one
are they relevant but two they're going
to have high volume and low competition
so let's take a look at an example in
Google's Keyword Planner so here I am
I'm in Google's Keyword Planner and as I
mentioned before Google's Keyword
Planner is situated under Google ads
okay so you have to have a Google ads
account to use Google's Keyword Planner
and so when you're in Google ads you
simply go to tools and then under Tools
you're going to select Keyword Planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to hone in on
some keywords so let's just use one of
the examples that Google's given us here
mail delivery so we're going to just
type in mail delivery and get some
results so notice I can enter a domain
as a filter and so in other words hey I
could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if I wanted to
but I'm asking Google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
I'm going to click click get results
notice I can add another key to it if I
wanted to but I'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that I can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just tone in on that one
key word mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what Google Keyword Planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here I
get a column for competition so I'm able
to see whether that's a very competitive
keyword or not and then just to give you
an extra Edge when you're choosing
keywords you can get a sense of what the
keyword May cost if you wanted to bid on
that for paid search so for mail
delivery I can see it's anywhere between
$746 and at the top of the page high
range
$16.61 so that should alert me to the
fact that hey if I'm going to try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's competitive by telling
me high competition but I know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit High well you
know I can see some other keywords here
that you know a dollar to $3 okay I
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the $7 they're suggesting so
that's a indication that the keyword is
highly competitive so the idea here
using Google's Keyword Planner is one we
want to get an idea of what other
keywords are out there that are relevant
so it helps stimulate some ideas for
relevancy two we can get an average
monthly search volume so we want to know
on average over the past 12 months how
many search queries I can expect from
this keyword and then three I can get a
sense of the competition how competitive
is this keyword so if I try to optimize
for this keyword and I want to rank for
it organically is it competitive if it's
competitive then it's probably going to
take me a bit longer to be found for
this keyword on page one of Google so
that's that's the whole idea behind
Google's Keyword Planner and note that
you could change some of the settings
here so if you want to choose a
different language okay you can hone in
on a longer or shorter period of time
you can even choose a specific location
so I chose texes I can certainly choose
the entire United States to get a sense
of what the volume would be for the
total us so you have settings that you
can change and manipulate to get you the
data you need to choose choose keywords
so that's the whole idea behind Google's
Keyword Planner to find relevant
keywords high volume low competition now
alternatively I can certainly use
another tool to find keywords so I have
a Moz account so I logged into MZ and MZ
has a tool called keyword Explorer so if
I use that same keyword I used in
Google's Keyword Planner mail delivery
I'm going to ask MZ to give me some data
on that keyword so this is for the
entire United States and again I can
change that if I wanted to okay so I can
hone in on a specific country or
different country so what Ma is telling
me hey for this keyword in the entire
United States I'm looking at anywhere
from
115,000 to 30,000 on monthly volume now
what MZ does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between one and 100 and so I
can see this is pretty much right down
the middle in terms of difficulty okay
so if it's zero it's an easy keyword if
it's if it's 100 it's very difficult and
then that means you have a lot of
competitors who are optimizing for this
keyword that are ranking for this
keyword and so Moz gives us the volume
they give us the competition and they
just like Google's Keyword Planner gives
us some other keywords that we can
potentially hone in on so here here I
can see keyword delivery plans delivery
services Etc so I can see a lot more
suggestions than what's listed here so
Moz delivers a bunch of other analysis
uh related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so MZ is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to Moz
related to SEO for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use Google's Keyword
Planner because maybe you're not running
Google ads you can always use Moz now
remember Moz has basically a freemium
version meaning you can sign up for a
free account and you can sign up for a
free account as a test trial and you
could test it for a period of days and
leverage its tools during that free
trial to get a better sense of how these
tools work so we want to be able to use
mods we want to be able to use Google's
Keyword Planner not only to search for
all those relevant keywords available to
you but we want to be able to choose
keywords with high volume and low
difficulty low competition we also want
to select primary and second keywords
wisely so remember when you optimize
you're optimizing a page for more than
one keyword so you want to be able to
have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so Moz gives you that
information and so we want to be able to
leverage the tools available to us to
choose the right keywords so if you need
any more information on this we got a
nice webinar on keyword research for SEO
so take a look at that video on YouTube
H to get more specific details about
using SEO tools for keyword research and
all about keyword research in general
for SEO so let's talk about some other
reasons under SEO what we would use some
of these tools available to us well we
want to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze linking to our web page
okay which ones are good which ones are
not good okay we also want to perform
some competitor analysis so these are
some of the reasons why other than
keyword research why would would we use
some of these SEO tools so we have tools
available to us Majestic HRS again M
let's take a look at Google search
console and I want to hone in on Google
search console because it is free and
it's a must if you're going to work on
SEO you need to be working in Google
search console and so the whole key
behind Google search console is you have
a website and you need to get that site
verified once it's verified once Google
can recognize that you are associated
with this website then you're going to
be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
Google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what Google does is is through
this platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these Pages back to their server
they're letting us know if we actually
have any issues so here I can see I have
some issues with 112 pages and some of
those issues are listed down here so
there could be a crawl issue a 44 you
know redirect okay so you could see
there's there some five unique issues
across 112 pages so here I can see
submitted URL marked no index there's a
100 of those pages we have some redirect
errors there's seven pages that you know
fall victim to this error and so we can
really hone in um what the ear is and
address the error okay so if Google's
telling us hey this is an issue and you
want that page indexed by Google then we
should probably address the error and so
that's the great thing here about going
into Google search console is you can
under index go to coverage and get a
sense of what Google's indexing and what
they're not indexing so these are the
errors I can see they've certainly were
able to crawl an index
9,115 Pages uh they were able to crawl
okay and they excluded
54,000 plus pages and then we also have
some pages with some warnings so this is
kind of an overview of what Google Sees
when they crawl our site so when they
say crawl they're coming to our site
they're following links on the site and
every link they follow they're either
going to index that page or they're
going to report to you an error or an
issue that they found if we want these
Pages index we need to address the
issues the errors and so that's the
beauty of this report here is Google is
telling us firsthand what the issues are
so we also want to take a look at the
sit map so you have an opportunity to
submit a sitemap and a sitemap is just a
formatted file that includes all your
website URLs and so you're going to have
this file sitting in your root directory
and you're probably going to call it or
should call it sitemap.xml XML being the
format so once you have this file you're
just going to let Google know that that
file exists so you're going to enter in
the sitemap URL so if it's in the root
directory all you're going to do is type
in sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this side is
done what Google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see that we discovered
1,419 URLs so I can go back under
coverage and I can see some of the
issues that they found but if I go back
under sit Maps I can see that these are
the URLs they discovered via the sitemap
and so the whole point of a Sit map is
we want to be able to get and push the
URLs to Google not have Google come to
our site and discover them so this is a
quicker faster more efficient way to
communicate with Google all the URLs
that you have on your site that you want
Google to index and so that's the beauty
of search console now while we're in
search console we might as well take a
look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report so Google is a
staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
Google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site fares
Via Mobile and when I say fares Via
Mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to Google
standards and so if there any issues
Google's going to let you know what
those issues are so here I could see
Google's recognized 206 pages with four
different issues okay so here I can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here I can see for
206 Pages text too small to read click
elements to close together the viewport
not set to device width and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if I
actually click on it the error I can see
what those 10 pages are and so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
Google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
Google telling Google look I see what
the issues are I'm going to fix them and
then I want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with Google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
Google's attention Google's going to
validate them and get these Pages index
quicker um so if you ignore the issues
and the errors especially for mobile
then you stand the chance of your pages
not getting index so the mobile
usability report to me is an important
report because we want to better
understand whether Google's picking up
issues on mobile and if they are we want
to address them get Google valid them so
Google can index them quicker now
there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you in Google search console and that's
the links report so the links report in
Google search console tells us what
pages have the most links okay so here
we can see the homepage say 26,000 plus
links if we hone in on interior Pages we
can see the links to those pages okay so
we can get a sense of what are the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on other websit sites pointing to
these pages I can also see internal
links so Google's recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another so external links internal links
both factors for SEO when ranking so
then I can see top linking sites what
sites are linking to my site and then I
can see top linking text so Google
search console is giving me kind of an
overview of what my leaking structure
looks like okay so external Al I want
links from other websites pointing to
various pages on my site and I certainly
want my pages linking to one another on
my site and so I'd be able to better
understand what that structure looks
like using Google search consoles links
report okay there's one more report that
I think's of interest in Google search
console and that's the performance
report so the performance report is a
report that actually you can link up
with Google analytics so you could see
the same same report and analytics if
you're able to link up Google search
console with analytics and you should be
able to do that all you need to do is
make sure you use the same email address
that you use for analytics and search
console so it needs to be the same email
address you could certainly link up the
two and have this data imported into
Google analytics so what is this data
that we're talking about well it's
called performance so what we can
actually see is the query queries the
actual queries people are typing in to
Google so when they're typing them into
Google we can actually see how many
Impressions the keyword queries received
and how many clicks the keyword queries
received and then I can see click the
rate and average position okay so here I
can see for this particular keyword on
the first line I can see over the course
of the last 3 months it received
29,200 297 Impressions so what does that
mean that means this keyword was used at
Le or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the Google search
results Pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209,000 plus times
this site received 120,000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click theid all
you need to do and Google can obviously
do this for you is you would simply just
divide the
29,029 into the
12,397 okay so that's really going to
give you that's going to give you your
click the rate and the click the rate in
this case is 57% so over half of the
clicks occur when this listing appears
for this keyword okay so we can get a
sense of the click your way for each one
okay and you can simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so we could see a
little bit more than that too we can go
from queries to Pages we can go from
pages to countries so we can get a sense
of how many Impressions and clicks I'm
receiving by country and importantly we
can see by device so here I can see a
majority of the people who conduct a
search related to my website primarily
do it on desktop now I mentioned the
beauty of the Google search console
performance report is that you can link
it up to Google analytics and when you
do that all you need to do then is go to
acquisition Google search console and
then from there you could choose landing
pages countries devices or queries so I
can see the same data that I see in
search console but this time I'm looking
at it in Google analytics and so here I
can see what my search queries are my
clicks my Impressions my click the rate
buy search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when I
link up Google search console with
analytics I'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we are going to use these
SEO tools available to us and so we
already listed a number of different
reasons ranging from site maps to
keyword research search but we also want
to hone in on you know what domains are
driving links to our site so I showed
you an example in search console we also
want to hey maybe identify and disavow
poor backlinks so search console is a
great tool for that because if we don't
want to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
clickthrough rates and Impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
Google search console report but if you
have a platform like MZ you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a Moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see for the keywords that we've
chosen that we want to optimize for we
could certainly see where they rank the
great thing about MZ is it's a great
tool not only for rankings and onpage
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so if I go ahead
and take a look at a domain for example
I'm just going to type in this domain
I'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain Authority so a score out
of one and 100 I'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
Moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links I have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if I click on the linking domains I'm
going to be act able to see the actual
domains pointing to my site as an
external link and not only can I see the
domains I can actually see the domain
authority of those domains so if there's
a domain for example that doesn't have a
good domain Authority and the site
appears a bit scammy per se then we can
disavow that so I can certainly look at
all the domains that are linking to me
me and then I can highlight the ones
that have poor domain Authority what Moz
even takes it a step further they also
give me a Spam score so Moz is able to
measure how spammy a website is so if I
have a combination of say a low domain
Authority and a high spam score then I
probably want to disavow myself from
that site and so I can use this report
here you could see here as I keep going
down for example I could see this
particular website has a domain
authority of 26 and it has a Spam score
of 16% so not a good combination this
should alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that I
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
Authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is I'm
able to hone in on not only who's L
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then I can get into a
little bit more detail and I actually
see you know all the links pointing to
that domain so it really goes into
detail about back links domain Authority
spam Etc everything you need to use in
order to measure off page SEO so that's
the great thing about mods is they have
not only onpage SEO tools but off page
SEO tools and Moz is a premium so to
speak so here you could see if you just
go to moz.com
free- se- tools you'll be able to use
some of these tools available to you not
just for SEO but also for local SEO as
well so here you like some of these
tools you can start your free 30-day
trial so I use and lean on Mo a lot for
all that it has to offer from choosing
keywords to rankings report to checking
issues on my website to even checking
who's linking to me so this fits in the
mold with everything I need to do for
SEO so in addition to that keyword
research video you could certainly lean
on some other webinars that we've done
in the past on SEO so we've done a
webinar on SEO tools and we've also done
a webinar on SEO tips and tricks so if
you want any more information about the
tools we covered or SEO in general take
a look at those two videos and check
them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools Google's Keyword
Planner uh MZ and Google search
console staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
any of our programs and set yourself on
the path to Career Success click the
link in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here